wir starten tatsächlich heute unser
neues Minecraft Projekt wir haben ja
Minecraft loser genommen und beiseite
geworfen und haben ja uns Gedanken
gemacht was man vielleicht zocken könnte
was vielleicht cool wä und uns
dementsprechend für ein Projekt
entschieden eigentlich müssen wir das
krasser ankündigen Sandy wir können
jetzt nicht einfach so die dies Dings
zeigen ein paar Sekunden
später wir spielen Minecraft loser noch
mal soll ich dich mal ganz kurz gegen
die Vitrine werfen ich habe mir einige
Gedanken gemacht was man spielen könnte
viele haben gesagt komm Laa macht mal
Skyblock Skyblock habe ich aber selber
schon gemacht auf Youtube deswegen habe
ich mir gesagt ne Skyblock ich nicht so
und zwar Sandy spielen wir das
hier das ist unsere Map Sandy ich ma mal
kurz Tag dass wir das ein bisschen
zumindest bei Tag eben kurz haben also
so geht's quasi
los und dann wir sterben doch na ja die
einzige Person die stirbt bist du
PvP ist hier deaktiviert Schlag du mich
mal wir können uns nicht schlagen ich ma
mal kurz eine Umfrage sollen wir das
machen mit PvP Ja oder Nein okay die
Abstimmung hat gesagt dass 77% wollen
dass wir PvP anmachen soll ich wirklich
[Musik]
anmachen dein er ja du hast gesagt ich
soll anmachen nicht mit runterchlagen ja
okay dann jetzt ohne schlagen ja
okay dier diese Frau ne ich RAS komplett
aus jetzt nur jetzt gar nicht mehr okay
jetzt sind wir quitt jetzt lassen wir es
okay okay Sandra Hand drauf schck deine
Hand in die Kamera einmal in in die
Kamera schütteln dass wir ein Handschlag
haben okay ich respawne mich jetzt wer
als erstes den runterchlägt der muss der
2000 € okay
okay
2 ich hab D gesch kleiner Hohn ich
erkläre euch erstmal ganz kurz was
onebock überhaupt ist ihr habt
wahrscheinlich bei allen möglichen
anderen Youtubern schon vor zwei Jahren
gesehen weil dann kam das ganze raus
also Sandra fängt schon an abzubauen das
ist nämlich der Sinn von onebock wir
können jetzt hier Blöcke abbauen und das
die ganze Zeit und da kommen immer neue
Blöcke die ganze Zeit bis wir irgendwie
bei Block 4000 sind oder so jedes Mal
töten ein ein Sub für den anderen ein
Sub schenken an den anderen dann
gewinnen ja nur die Zuschauer ma einfach
ein Z für jedes töten ab jetzt okay
ja damit Sandra auch mal ein bisschen
Geld
verdient ich setze jetzt auch hier mal
den Setzling hin damit hier quasi schon
Baum wächst
ähm mach do noch mal hängen da mal die
Äpfel dran haben wir ein
Apfelbaum also so meinst du ah dann wir
ein Apfelbaum ja oder
doch ja recht soll ich noch mal Samen
reinschmeißen hier so vielleicht dann so
ja soll ich noch mal mit Wasser ein
bisschen Gießen ja okay ich habe dich
geprankt ich wollte die Sachen nur
haben kann man das rückgängig
machen ich habe gerade eine Spinne
gehört wo ist die Spinne immer wenn man
Block abbaut kommt der Sound oh mein
Gott you having
R ich ma mir in die Hosen guck mal hier
alle die schreiben Gras ist wichtig ja
ja kam schon fünf grasblöcke seitdem
dann bau die doch weiter aus
ja
oh wie süß 20 Sekunden
später okay wir haben jetzt eine ganz
eine
ganz e wer hat diese Frau verarscht wo
ist das für dich denn bitte eine ganz
ja
Ende kann es sein dass du dumm bist ich
hatte gerade Text zu speech und zwar
fragt Luca jemand das wir finde ich auch
interessant Luca Z wenn es diese Map in
echt geben würde und du Luca da dein
ganzes Leben leben müsstest welche fünf
gegensste würdest du mitnehmen also auf
jeden Fall würde ich erstm meineos
mitnehmen dein erster Gegenstand auf
einsame Insel W deine eikos ja ich würde
jeden Tag zwei hats
Rauchen diger bist du verloren Eiern
kommt irwi nie was raus also Leute wir
streamen heute nicht so lange weil Luca
noch ein Date
hat aus Eiern kommt nie was raus zwei
hüchen Leute ich würde den setzding hier
hinsetzen dann haben wir auf jeden Fall
schon mal unendlich Holz und dann würde
ich es so sagen dass wir eine große
Plattform bauen hier irgendwie so ein so
so ein rundes Ding und dann geht das
rüber mit so einzelnen wegen zu so
kleinen Inseln dann baut sich da vorne
Sand eine kleine Insel kann sie machen
was will ich baue mir hier eine dann
machen wir vorne irgendwie Monsterfarm
brauchen wir ja wir brauchen generell
eine Farm für unser ganzes Essen und so
wir sind auch immer im Thema Planes
gerade aktuell also es gibt ja
verschiedene Themen alle die jetzt
gerade neu mit dabei sind das heißt hier
SP wie kann denn Sandra zweimal auf dem
Server sein mein Hühnerhaus ist
gescheitert die können
rausfliegen das sollte ein Hühnerhaus
werden
ja ich bau das übrigens alles in halben
Block tiefer warum ich weiß nicht was
denkst du warum ich das ein halben Block
tiefer
Bau damit es eine Stufe wird wegen der
Monster damit h keine Monster drauf
spawen Sandy denn Monster können
tatsächlich nur spawnen wenn das ganze
auf einer Höhe ist quasi mit diesem one
block hier vorne
kom
Leben ich kann ihn nicht schlagen oh
mein
Gott warum stirbst du gerade wel ich WD
vergiftet mich der ganze Laden
anguckt die
[Musik]
Wicher
wie findet ihr mein Gehege bis jetzt oh
ich habe mich bisschen
verbaut also hast du irgendwas
mitbekommen was bei mir gerade passiert
ist in letzten 30 Sekunden nee was denn
dein er ja die sollen jetzt erstmal alle
hier rein wieso machst du das denn nur
ein Block
breit weil wir nicht mehr
haben was last du wir haben übel viel
ich sehe gar nichts also schau mal ich
kann das jetzt hier zen und Weizenkorn
anpflanzen jetzt können wir mit
Knochenmehl drauf gehen so dass es halt
wächst jetzt haben wir ein Weizen das
Problem ist jetzt nehme ich halt die
Weizenkörner und Pflanz die quasi weiter
an dann muss ich mit ganzen kN genau
dann gib das aber mal dem Schaf damit es
ist das Schaf warum willst du unbedingt
dass das Ding ist weil es komm doch es
kommt wir brauchen
Bett keine Monster spawnen nein aber
jetzt kommen diese Dinger dass man nach
drei Tagen wenn man nicht schläft das
Ding kommt ah oh mein Gott Sandra denkt
mit ja m ich will mit den nen Bizeps ich
verabschiede mich ne ich wünsche eine
tolle Nacht ja Leute ich würde jetzt
auch hier vom Server runtergehen hat mir
uns auf jeden Fall sehr viel Spaß
gemacht und wir sehen uns beim nächsten
Stream wieder Leute Laser ich wünsch dir
was viel Spaß beim
[Musik]
Date